in the seventh episode of Star Trek
Picard the character split up his L nor
remains on the Borg artifact the card
and Shoji go visit old friends and the
rest of the Lost sea Rena crew heads
after him here are all the Easter eggs
and references you might have missed in
Nepenthe when Picard and Shoji are
confronted in the woods at Nepenthe by
Will Riker and Deanna Troi his daughter
Kestrel she points her bow and arrow at
Picard's heart but he tells her she may
want to aim at his head instead since
his heart is made of solid dirt a neom
Picard's artificial heart was first
established as cannon in the second
season episode Samaritan snare in which
Picard has to undergo an operation to
replace the deteriorating mechanical
organ Picard says his original heart
replacement occurred after being stabbed
through the back by a group of Nasik ins
when he was younger which he tells
Wesley was a curious sensation how much
pain
shock suddenly at the sight of serrated
metal sticking through my chest later in
the sixth episode tapestry we actually
see this confrontation play out thanks
to some time meddling from cue when
Picard visits Will Riker and Deanna Troi
we learned that the couple has had two
children in the time that has passed
since Star Trek nemesis their first the
boy named Thad would have been 18 in
$23.99 but tragically passed away
several years earlier at the time of
Nepenthe they have only one surviving
child of Berk OSHA's teen with a vivid
imagination named kes truck both of the
Troi Riker children were actually named
for members of their parents families as
revealed in the Voyager episode death
wish Thaddeus Riker was a soldier in the
Union Army during the American Civil War
whose life was saved by a queue named
Quinn that is colonel Thaddeus Riker
after he was wounded at Pine Mountain
they used to call him old iron boots but
what that Troi Riker was named for a
distant ancestor of his father
Chester got her name from a much closer
relation to her mother as revealed in
the next generation episode dark page
Kester Troy was Diana's older sister who
died as a child in a tragic accident
Deanna didn't know about Castro until
she was an adult when she helped her
mother finally work through her
decades-old grief and guilt over
kestrels death in Rikers first seen in
Picard he's working in the kitchen
preparing ingredients for homemade pizza
while listening to jazz both of these
pastimes are things Picard's erstwhile
number one often enjoyed in between
shifts on the enterprise in the next
generation season
- episode x squared Riker makes
scrambled eggs from scratch for his
fellow crew mates using owen eggs he
picked up at their last stop at Starbase
73 unfortunately it turns out that Owen
eggs aren't appetizing to humans and
most of Riker's guests can't manage more
than a mouthful in his defense Riker
says a cook is only as good as his
ingredients indepent the Riker seems to
have learned his lesson using tomatoes
and basil from his own garden in his
pizza meanwhile will Rikers love for
jazz was first shown in the next
generation season 1 episode 1 1 0 0 1 0
0 1 in that episode an alien species
called the bynars distracts Riker by
keeping him on the holodeck where he
plays trombone with a 1958 New Orleans
jazz combo after learning that shoji is
a synthetic modeled after Commander data
castro begins quizzing her new
acquaintances on her interests and
abilities no do you like Sherlock Holmes
I guess so data first picked up the
violin in order to get into character of
Sherlock Holmes in the next generation
season 2 episode Elementary dear data in
the episode data and Geordi are
confronted with a hologram of Holmes's
arch nemesis Moriarty who begins to gain
sentience the themes of elementary deer
data about artificial intelligence which
becomes self-aware are very similar to
those of the card Kestrel also asked
whether Sochi has any enhanced physical
abilities like bending metal with her
bare hands on the next generation this
was one of the demonstrations that Riker
himself uses to argue against data's
humanity in the episode the measure of a
man fortunately despite Riker presenting
a strong case on behalf of Bruce Maddox
the judge rules in data and records
favor it is the ruling of this court
that Lieutenant Commander data has the
freedom to choose Riker later apologizes
the data for arguing that he wasn't a
person but data immediately absolves him
telling him that if he hadn't done it
data would never have been given the
opportunity to defend himself in the
first place
after quizzing shoji on whether she
inherited any of her interests and
abilities from her father data Castro
moves on to her biological functions
wondering if her synthetic body produces
things like saliva and mucus when Sochi
confirms that it does caspere amuses
that it would make sense a data
synthetic offspring would have so many
of these biological traits since he was
always trying to be more human she goes
on to explain that despite
of datas impressive android abilities
all he ever really wanted to do were
things like have dreams tell jokes and
learn how to ballroom dance theta was
featured doing all three of these
activities during various episodes of
Star Trek The Next Generation data first
started experiencing dreams in the sixth
season episode birthright part one after
that episode he said that he planned to
incorporate dreaming into his regular
routine he also repeatedly tried to tell
jokes throughout the next generations
run and even received lessons in humor
from a holographic stand-up comedian in
the season 2 episode the outrageous of
canna I come from a town so small we had
a fraction for a zip code and he Illyria
Slee asks for dancing lessons from dr.
crusher in the season 4 episode data's
day which also features the return of
Bruce Maddox due to a miscommunication
crusher teaches data to tap-dance when
what he really needed to learn was
ballroom dancing for an upcoming wedding
while attempting to persuade Rios and
Rafi to abandon Picard and return to
Earth Agnes said she'd hoped to be the
fun crew member who says things like
let's hide in that comment and it turns
out to be a giant gormogon or something
gormogon ders resemble giant space
whales and were first seen in the Star
Trek Discovery episode magic to make the
same an go mad in which a character hid
inside an injured Ghormeh gander in an
attempt to smuggle himself onboard the
discovery and take over the ship but of
course hiding in a comment that turns
out to be a giant organic life-form is
also a clear reference to that other
hugely popular space saga in The Empire
Strikes Back Han Solo hides from the
Imperial Navy by piloting the Millennium
Falcon into a cave in an asteroid which
turns out to actually be the mouth of a
giant space look when trying to convince
the adults around the dinner table that
a friend captain Crandall would be the
ideal candidate to transport Ricard and
Shoji offworld on a ship Kestrel brags
about Randall's travel saying it's been
everything chrono seconds breath Kono's
has been mentioned many times throughout
Star Trek history as the home of the
Klingon Empire and picard and his crew
have even visited it a few times
meanwhile Titans rift isn't a planet but
rather a type of spatial anomaly that
absorbs all the surrounding energy the
enterprise became trapped in a tycoons
rift in the next generation season 4
episode night terrors and that episode
counselor Troi was the one who worked
out the solution so that the enterprise
could finally break free of the rip
years later we see that Picard is still
seeking advice from Troy to get himself
out of seemingly impossible situations
and that she is more than willing to
give it check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Star Trek er coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]